oh my God
it's like any other training session
but with one difference
I enjoy playing football because yeah
when I mean the game when I'm in the
pitch
I'm really amazed my thoughts my my joy
is up there because
well my dream becomes reality
initially I I so much admired guys would
play football live and we used to play
football
players use a ball that rattles
and with varying levels of visual
impairment the playing field has leveled
with blindfolds
the Love of the Game runs deep
before blindness I would say footballers
football itself is part of me and I'm
also part of football because before we
came blind in 2016 I was a footballer so
it was nothing new that attracted me to
football because I know the importance
of football
yeah and this blind football league says
it's helped make the community more
inclusive
Community has greatly welcomed this
sport because whenever we go in the
communities and organize like inclusive
Masters or demonstration exhibition
matches
so many people converge around us and
always have that that imagination how
can a blind person play so they always
want to be to understand how can a blind
person play football
with the sport continuing to grow there
are hopes that the World Cup might well
give it another boost
Paul vanderworth Al Jazeera